I'm surgery it will be fine pounding
surgery I know how to divert all the fat
intake to my chest
you can't just fine we'll work on it
okay I guess I'll tuck it in I would die
I reject nation we're gonna watch
something that's totally not linked to
that conversation
this is Renee Arielle yeah you guys know
her she's on clever news yeah and also
on Instagram and Twitter guys follow her
there right away I'm telling you it's
it's a very inspiring page she has a
dating blog sexting in the city and the
city my bad if you want to get good at
dating I'll help you one-on-one insult
say we're gonna watch this trailer today
for a Clint Eastwood directed film close
the mule Clint Eastwood makes good
movies most of the time that's what this
is all about that's about drugs
we love drugs say yes to drugs that's
what my dear program taught me in the
90s yeah oh no it's a dead body isn't it
Wow source drugs no it's definitely
drugs those drugs cocaine I knew it
[Laughter]
no no what I'm fine thank you okay
[Music]
she's a little bit nervous oh dude oh oh
who knows he's like this dog serious
kill the dog
no family's the most important thing
that's true don't do what I did let it
work in front of family life lessons I
thought it was more important to be
somebody out there then the unfair you
are was in my own home
[Music]
was a terrible father
it's like Breaking Bad
my chance there is its Fishburne I
didn't deserve forgiveness Michael Pena
this is the last one
it's gonna be on Christmas as well
oh my god
it's true
Andy Garcia
oh my god you're looking at us it looks
like it that looks so cool that looks so
cool man
damn you don't really good job with that
trailer I will say it's another December
movie I can't wait to watch 86 movies in
December that looks really good
it does I'm not really into movies like
this that are too intense action-packed
no those drug dealing types of movies
with your action and like crime you
don't want to watch a 95 year old man
there's something about this and I
thought they just did a really good job
with the trailer where I was on the edge
of my seat what's gonna happen I felt
bad for this old man yeah get go with
the cocaine and his bed with his PKM bad
cover story though he talked too much
that's how you know someone's lying when
they like oh that's bad tasting pecan
pie that's sure one thing I hate in
movies is when a character has to lie
and we know the characters lying but
they suck at lying although I felt like
you know he seemed nervous and I thought
for the most part you know I feel like I
could sort of believe him if I wasn't
the cop but a lot of the times in these
movies you like you're so obviously
lying cut it out dude I mean out of the
fact that he's talking too much it just
seemed like breaking bad in a way of
yeah guy who is a failure and career or
failure to his family that he finds his
way like - white man working with the
drug cartel it's like this drug business
I'm not exactly sure what he's doing
he's a drug I would assume so what's a
drug mule they like bring the drugs to
the other side of the right from Mexico
that's what a drug mule is I think I'm
acting like I know should I google this
really quick this would not be on
dictionary I thought this would be an
urban dictionary
I feel like drug person or trans knows a
person who transfers the drugs on them
or concealed him in a body cavity you
think he would oh my oh my god did you
see the image go back what I'm not
looking go oh this right here yes it's
hot Oh oh my god are you using this for
the video Wow okay so that's what a drug
mule is
karyam I mean maybe not just from Mexico
- good probably from just over overseas
it's good that you know because cocaine
it's a good thing you know
the drug mule thing because this could
have been that thing of where you know
people are commenting going huh the girl
in the video doesn't know anything but
now I'm the guy who doesn't know
anything and the girl has educated me
hashtag is one of those many women
empowerment things
hashtag Renee - I know nothing about
like prices of drugs or anything but I
hear the brakes of several they can be
very pricey man that was a lot to have a
mere drunk don't ask me how I know but
just a little tiny baggie of you know
[Music]
cost like 50 bucks he should have kept
it in a body body part like it would
have been less suspicious when he opens
the trunk or the gun the other part that
was surprising to me about this trailer
is clint eastwood even though what he's
doing is technically a job that will
require someone being tough the way his
performance was of what we saw in this
trailer was not mr. tough guy Clint
Eastwood which is what I'm so used to
seeing him do that's what we all love
him for it's a more sensitive side to
Clint Eastwood that I'm not used to
seeing I'm very much drawn to that and I
kind of like the idea too of you know
you spend time with the guy who's gonna
be taken down by the end of the movie
but you're also spending time whoever
those agents are they're like Bradley
Cooper Michael Pena all them are doing
so you're gonna see both sides of this
of the tale here
Bradley Cooper start an American sniper
which was directed by Clint Eastwood and
now we're gonna see them on screen
together that's kind of a cool little
Easter Egg to have in this film that's
pretty cool so I'm wondering if the the
plot is like he gets caught maybe early
on and then instead of busting him
they're gonna use him to catch the big
guys oh that might be a more interesting
tale that's why I think Bradley Cooper's
with
and I would assume because they're like
kind of gonna work together and that's
maybe the can't run forever I mean or
maybe the trailer just spoiled it that
that Bradley Cooper's gonna just
identify him in that scene that could be
it could be a twist that maybe comes in
later on in the movie sort of his path
to redemption because I can get a little
sick of the trope this guy does bad
things but he has a family so it's okay
to sympathize for him because that's
essentially what this film is playing on
but it could make more use of its
elements if you do kind of get down that
more interesting bath because it looks
like Linnaeus was gonna be going at some
very interesting terrain like you so
there's that one scene with Andy Garcia
firing a you know a golden shotgun and
this was a pretty fancy cartel action
you got going over so he's gonna be
going down some interesting paths but
the performance here looks great from
Clint Eastwood I like and he rarely
stars in movies these days especially
the ones that he's directing himself so
I'm excited to see Clint Eastwood doing
that the whole cast looks awesome this
this feels very intense it feels
personal and I like to that they're not
portraying him as a good father
he's portrayed as a guy who is awful hey
you know makes it more realistic yes
when you like dedicate your life to this
you're obviously not gonna be like a
great family man as well so I'm happy
they kept that realistic well also
having us feel bad for you is impressive
the driller it's a more real way to care
as opposed to a cheap gimmick of you
know even though he does this drug mule
stuff he's a good guy instead of like
playing on that factory like it's just a
real guy and he just failed in life and
it makes sense all right guys well are
you excited for the mule are you gonna
skip movies like bumblebee and Aquaman
and Mary Poppins returns this Christmas
watch the mule listen Mary Poppins
that's that's me man I go for the far
the hard shots there you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification melka subscribe button
suck and also check out Renee on
Instagram and Twitter where she's
constantly teaching you guys more about
the drug industry yep take care of
people bye-bye now